you got a scar on your head how to do
this I was um
I was 11 years old me and my brother
that looks like an 11 year old like that
was like
yeah oh I mean my brother was playing
Whip and fight you heard it playing what
whipping fight weapon fight yeah like
you hit me with a brick but I hit you
with a bottle in your head wait you
threw a brick yeah this is a game in
Louisiana Whip and fight weapon fight
women fight
so you so if I hit you with a you my
brother hit me in the head with a brick
and I hit him in the head with a bottle
I got a Skywalker he got a scar on the
Becky head what the [__] yeah we bad
here bro
that's some wild ass [__] yeah but like
like most like like just my fans they
all this they love it you know what I'm
saying did your parents beat y'all's ass
when they found it cracking bottles and
Bricks over each other's heads
I come home and one of my both of my
sons are leaking yeah oh I'm fine but my
mom was on [__] like because it was in
my face it was in my face so that's my
only scar in my face yeah you know what
I'm saying and my mom was like you
[__] my son face up you black [__] oh
she talking like this with my older
brother yeah but you turn around and be
like Bro Look he hit me too so so she
like she sleep on me I'm like I thought
you was just on my side and you're a
smaller brother right I'm the middle
you're the Middle Brother Mr Big Brother
who hit you in the head with a brick my
oldest brother Jesus yeah is he here
I don't know if I just like we should
talk how many times did you guys play
this game he don't know why he hit me
though I don't know and I want to know
how did it start did it start with a
brick in a box I walked outside and I
was I was missing him oh my God oh he
was sitting on the curb he they were
playing ball curveball and my older
brother playing curveball so I ran up
and smacked me back ahead because he'll
bald head so I smacked in Vegas
yeah this the one I ate with the glass
bottle so I like I smacked them back in
the head but I ran back in the house
about to you know hide from and [__] so
I came back outside it was squiggly
what's the matter
I was glad you didn't die yeah for real
Grace got it but I'm like remember was
hit me like boom I'm like just leaking
yeah but I ain't feel it though you know
what I'm saying so now you know with the
bottle I knocked him out though because
I tried to do that if you're the big
dude
who is the little dude
the little dude is right here
your brother yeah God Rest his soul I
have a friend we call him the baby dude
he's this little fat asian guy wow
His Radio name is Baby Joel but he's
also a dude so we just call him the baby
dude he's a little short fat asian guy
he looks like the baby dude the baby I
gotta meet him you might meet up Super
Bowl yeah
the big dude meet the baby dude yeah
dude together
do some dude [__]